for all the neighbors traumatized in the
wake of the shocking and disturbing
incident Philadelphia Mourns with all of
you I want to thank commissioner Outlaw
and the police department for their
response to this terrible tragic
incident police responded immediately
and courageously getting victims to the
hospital and successfully apprehending
the armed suspect in a short amount of
time likely preventing more deaths and
may I say that scene must have been
chaotic they were taken active fire
scooping people up getting to trying to
get into the hospital to save them and
our officers deserve our great debt of
gratitude for their courage and for
their commitment to philadelphians and
frustrated outrage that mass shootings
like this continue to happen in
communities across the United States
this country needs to re-examine its
conscience and find out how to get guns
out of dangerous people's hands
a person walking down the city street
with an AR style rifle and shooting
randomly at people while wearing a
bulletproof vest with multiple magazines
is disgraceful but all too common
situation in America and I was today at
the city at the Independence Hall where
they wrote that Constitution and the
second amendment was never intended to
protect this
this was a terrible tragic situation and
it's traumatized the community we are
begging Congress to protect lives and do
something about America's gun problem uh
now I'll turn it over to police
commissary Outlaw for updates on this
incident
yeah
thank you Mr Mayor first and foremost I
would like to express my deepest
condolences to the families friends and
all of those affected by this senseless
act of violence our hearts go out to
them during this unimaginable and
unimaginably difficult time everyone
everyone you see here today and not here
in this room
is committed to finding answers to what
happened last night and Seeking Justice
for the victims and their families
as the investigation into this tragic
incident continues I kindly ask for your
patience and your understanding our
investigators are working tirelessly to
gather and analyze all available
evidence ensuring a thorough and
comprehensive investigation
it is crucial that we allow them the
time and resources necessary to uncover
the truth which includes the why
that said let me be crystal clear
what happened last night in our
concession neighborhood was unimaginably
disgusting and horrifying
on what was supposed to be a beautiful
summer evening this armed and armored
individual wreak havoc firing with a
rifle at their victims seemingly at
random shooting seven killing five
including children
babies
such an act of violence is abhorrent and
goes against everything we stand for in
this community
I too would like to take a moment to
recognize the Valor of our courageous
officers
the actions of our 12th District
officers and supervisors last night
these officers swiftly and immediately
responded to a radio call reporting a
person with a gun and an active shooting
situation in the 1600 block of South
56th Street
while tending to victims at that
location they heard multiple gunshots at
the intersection of 56th Street and
concessing Avenue
some of the responding officers promptly
tended to the wounded and rushed them to
an area Hospital
While others fearlessly ran toward the
sounds of gunfire
with remarkable bravery and
determination they pursued the suspect
on foot
as they fled from concessing Avenue onto
Frazier Street all while they continued
to discharge their weapon
the officers persisted in their Pursuit
along Frazier Street and successfully
apprehended the suspect in the rear
alley of 1600 Frazier Street without any
further incident or injury
again I commend these officers for their
unwavering bravery
their Swift actions undoubtedly saved
additional lives
at this time I want to emphasize that we
currently have no reason to believe that
there are additional suspects or an
ongoing threat to the community as it
relates to this incident we're confident
that we have the individual responsible
in custody however we do ask for your
continued patience and cooperation as I
mentioned before as we meticulously
piece together the events leading up to
this heinous act
I want to assure the public that the
Philadelphia Police Department is fully
committed to ensuring the Safety and
Security of our communities we will
exhaust all efforts in our pursuit of
justice for the victims the families and
the neighborhood
in closing I want to express our
gratitude for the support and
understanding of the public and the
media during this challenging time your
cooperation is essential as we worked
alongside our law enforcement Partners
to uncover the facts and provide some
semblance of closure to this devastating
event
please continue to keep everyone
involved in this and affected by this
uplifted in prayer
now I'd like to invite staff inspector
Ernest Ransom the commanding officer of
our homicide unit to provide the case
details as we currently know them
staff instructor
thank you commissioner
nice good afternoon
so yesterday evening approximately 8 28
PM officers from the 12th District
responded to a radio call person with a
gun shooting at 1600 South 56th Street
officers then located multiple shooting
victims at several locations they were
suffering multiple gunshots to the body
six shooting victims were transported to
Penn Presbyterian Medical Center where
four of the victims were pronounced dead
two of the victims are currently listed
in stable condition two additional
juveniles are treated in Area Hospital
one suffering from a gunshot wound to
the leg the other sustained injuries to
the eyes caused by shattered grass glass
those individuals again are listed in
stable condition
all right based on our Witnesses
interviews and recovered video The
Suspect while wearing body armor a ski
mask and holding a AR-15 assault rifle
was observed at several locations near
56th Street near Chester Avenue and
Springfield Avenue the suspect then
began shooting Amos Lee at occupied
vehicles and individuals on the street
as they walked the suspect fired at the
vehicles being operated by a mother who
was driving her to her set of twins home
one of the twins suffered a gunshot
wound to the leg their sibling sustained
a gunshot sorry sustained injuries to
the eyes from shattered glass
so while assistant shooting victims
officers heard multiple gunshots in the
area and observed the suspect after a
brief foot pursuit officers made contact
with the suspect in the rear Alleyway of
Springfield Avenue officers engaged that
suspect where he was where they were
able to apprehend the suspect without
incident officers were able to locate a
nine millimeter of nine millimeter
handgun and an AR-15 style assault rifle
none of the victims engaged the suspect
or were aware the suspect was going to
inflict this act of violence upon them
we believe the ceased victim at the
location inside of 1600 South 56th
Street was the first shooting victim
however due to the victim being home
alone the victim was not discovered by
family members to hours after the
incident
our our deceased are again is al-assad
Merit a 20 year old male A.D mower
Stanton a 29 year old male a Ralph
Morales a 59 year old male a Dijon Brown
a 15 year old male and a Joseph warmoff
Junior a 31 year old male
the investigation again is currently
being reviewed by the District
Attorney's Office uh the suspect as of
now has not been charged we do expect
charges to become a forthcoming
[Music]
I would now turn off to a
district attorney krasner
good afternoon I want to um Echo and
support all the comments that you have
heard from the mayor the police
commissioner and the more specific
comments about the investigation itself
I agree with every bit of it and I don't
want to repeat it
but there are a couple things I do want
to say first of all
[Music]
there are different things that a
prosecutor's office does in a situation
like this and the first thing that we do
at the same time as we're providing
whatever assistance is needed to law
enforcement in its investigation is we
try to make sure victims survivors
Witnesses and other people traumatized
by an absolute nightmare happening on
the street
have their needs addressed and make no
mistake what the police officers went
through out there a couple of whom I
spoke with
just this morning when I was out there
having to scoop
injured or dying people into a vehicle
at a time when there are shots going off
everywhere when they have no way to
protect their own backs having to do
that
is rough having to do it all night is
rough getting two hours of sleep and
then being back out there this morning
is rough
there's a lot of people who had a very
very hard time
last night but our first step is that is
to reach out to those who have been
affected and for that reason
we are happy that there are 58 people
who work in the DA's office on victim
witness issues including the grant
funded cares team
the purpose of which is to deal with the
families of homicide victims intensively
for the first 45 days
all of them have been deployed with the
single exception of the 15 year old
victim who was not identified until
recently we have been in contact with
every single family trying to do
whatever we can to support them and
there is so much support that they need
at this phase we will continue to work
with them but also work with the
community that is deeply deeply affected
by what happened out there I can tell
you what I saw this morning what I saw
this morning on a beautiful July 4th
when the temperature wasn't too hot this
morning there were little sprinkles but
it was otherwise a beautiful day was
completely empty streets I saw every
porch empty I saw every door closed I
saw every curtain where there was a
curtain pulled I saw no kids playing I
saw a bicycle
that had been left there from the time
of the shooting
sitting on a corner untouched apparently
untouched for 12 or more hours
nobody coming out to move it to take it
to touch it or anything else as if
everybody understood what happened here
was so horrible
that for right now this is a desert and
for right now everything that we
associate with celebrating 4th of July
is off
that was step one for us
step two for us
is the charging I've been in close
contact with the head of our homicide
non-fatal shooting unit with the very
experienced attorney who is assigned to
this case we are well aware of a lot of
investigative details that we are not in
a position to put out here and will not
put out here but I can tell you this the
man who did this is in custody the man
who did this will be facing multiple
counts of murder and will also be facing
multiple counts of aggravated assault as
a first degree felony weapons charges
among others we will be able to be more
specific tomorrow it is expected that
the preliminary arraignment which is the
first public event in a case like this
where bail will be set at held without
bail in other words this is a person who
is never going to leave jail before the
trial and it is my expectation is never
going to leave jail period but the first
public event will be occurring tomorrow
either during the work day in the
morning or possibly later in the
afternoon depending upon the demands
that are placed upon this queue
by which people come up for their
arraignment at that time it will be
possible to say more publicly although
not everything understand we are in a
situation where some of the detectives
working hardest on this did not sleep
all night
and I know this because
I need to have a really well written
Affidavit of probable cause
for the purpose here and I am well aware
that the detective who was working on
that I'll keep his name out of it
I had to get some sleep he'd been up
without any kind of rest all night he
was out there this morning again
but he needed a few hours sleep so he
could write the best affidavit you can
write because that's what we need to
prosecute a case properly so phase one
for us was really to reach out and try
to support all those so adversely
affected phase two is the beginning of a
vigorous criminal prosecution of a truly
atrocious horrific
act it will either be prosecuted
by this office or possibly by the feds
if so
they will have our complete cooperation
as they always do and we always look
forward to working with them
jointly finally I just want to say this
it is
disgusting
the lack
of proper gun legislation that we have
in the Commonwealth of Pennsylvania I
cannot agree more heartily with the
mayor it is disgusting that you can go
to New Jersey and find a whole list
of reasonable gun regulation that we
don't have that you can go to Delaware
and there's almost as long a list of
reasonable gun legislation that we don't
have some of that legislation might have
made a difference here
and it is time
for everybody and our legislature
including the ones who would like to
walk around with an AR-15 lapel pin it
is time for every one of them
to face the voters
and if they're not going to do something
then voters are going to have to vote
them out because that's what that lapel
pin means it means vote me out I am
against you and I'm against your safety
and a lot of us have had enough of that
I can tell you I certainly have had
enough of it I would ask everyone I know
how painful this is how emotional it is
everyone who is there we intend to help
you any way we can we know the police
department does we know the city does we
intend to help you any way we can please
do not think in terms of any kind of
violent response please do not think in
terms of anything other than peace on
the streets
the man who has done this horrible thing
is in a jail cell he's going to stay
there you cannot get to him to hurt him
so please do not hurt anyone else thank
you
I think we have time for a couple of
questions
[Music]
dad was wearing
both of us had the handgun to have the
AR style rifle is there any reason to
believe
pre-medicated attack against the
community
again there's only so much that we can
divulge at this time but I I think it is
safe to say that with the evidence that
we do have available to us that these
acts were done knowingly and
intentionally
well that's for the investigators to to
find out I mean it's not just going back
and speaking to Witnesses but it's also
once we get the ability to speak to the
suspect as well and then also
identifying any uh Communications that
have been made by the person in custody
prior as well
secondary suspect yesterday that had
been arrested we understand that
individual was released and not charged
is there any reason behind that there is
a second person who was investigated the
investigation is ongoing but I can tell
you based upon limited information I I
have that we do not see a basis for
concluding that that person's discharge
of a firearm was illegal
when you are under Fire in a mass
shooting there are rights to protect
others and rights to protect yourself
obviously the investigation is not
complete but we are not in the practice
of holding people in custody when we
don't have probable cause and when when
we believe that their actions were
lawful that's all I can say in that
point at this time
[Music]
not at this time
not at this time no ma'am
[Music]
investigator
it's wrong
well I can't say if his criminal history
would have prevent him from possession
any weapons but again as you said he has
not been criminally charged as of yet so
um again that will be investigated
that's part of our investigation
first victim he's had a son inside the
house a couple hours after when do we
believe that the shooting started and
were people outside enjoying like Fourth
of July festivities
well we got the initial call at right
here
so we get called at 8 28. we find the
last shooting victim at 12 19. so it's a
possible it happened prior to 8 28 but
um
no there's no indication that that was
the issue at all we believe it it
appears this individual acted alone and
did what he did for whatever the reasons
made then
not that he was talking to any
individuals
ma'am
[Music]
well what I can say is he was in charge
in this particular situation
um based on the evidence that we have
recovered and again as the district
attorney stated this investigation is
still a long one
um it appears he did act it in
self-defense
ma'am were the guns that the individual
was using traceable specifically
not that I cannot sell discuss right now
not to my knowledge
okay so this could be the last question
any other additional updates we get
we're going to put out uh thank you so
much
this incident had nothing to do with
July 4th or tonight's concert last
year's incident had nothing to do with
July 4th and the concert it happened a
mile a mile and a half two maybe two
miles away to to link these incidents
with the July 4 celebration is wrong
it's wrong and it's not helpful
um and uh we will have adequate security
this year as we did last year as we did
the year before all the way back to
other Mayors nothing happened on the
footprint of the site and this is King
sessing and it's not even close uh to
where the concert's going to be and the
person's in custody there's no issue of
a of any kind of conspiracy uh and so
the linkage is false
thank you thank you
good job
foreign